why are you so dark you're really pretty
for a dark-skinned girl it's just me
where did you get darker you're lucky
you don't even have to worry about
getting tagged in the summer because
it's not like you're gonna get any
darker these are just stupid ridiculous
things I have had said to me over the
years simply because of my skin tone
women are using the hashtag unfair and
lovely to criticize creams that bleach
or lighten your skin like this one fair
and lovely millions of women around the
world use creams like that to lighten
their skin some ads for these products
have already been banned in countries
like India to university students from
Austin Texas decided they want to fight
what they see as prejudiced and racist
beauty ideals one time I was walking
here at the University and this South
Asian boy was like dark-skinned but the
walk I've had bleach balloons thrown at
me
it all just happened yeah like I was
telling someone I do a photo series
every single season nothing ever happens
so this one just it just kind of blew up
on its own did you achieve your goal
with this what it's achieved is
self-love for a community that for
communities that desperately need it I
think it has achieved us reclaiming
notions of being dusky or dark I think
that we have achieved what we sought out
to do we've gone beyond that honestly